although he expects to eventually get
crushed by gargantua's gravity Cooper is
miraculously spared once his shuttle is
ripped apart and that's when things get
crazy after surviving the Wild Ride
Cooper gets transported to an infinite
interdimensional library that allows him
to look back into different moments in
his daughter's childhood bedroom tars
determines that they made it through
Gargantua alive because they were
protected by them the mysterious beings
who constructed the wormhole in the
first place since the beginning of the
film who they are has been a mystery
while NASA realized the Wormhole was
artificially constructed by some sort of
advanced intelligent beings they didn't
have any information about them beyond
the assumption that they must be
benevolent tars deduces they also must
have built this library to help Cooper
understand their five-dimensional
reality and sure it's confusing but it's
also nice to have otherworldly beings on
your side